IT’S CALLED THE 1620 PROJECT AND
WE WILL EXPLAIN IT TO YOU.
BUT FIRST, A NATIONAL SCANDAL IS
UNFOLDING BEFORE OUR EYES WHICH
IS NOT UNUSUAL AS AN ENTIRE
GENERATION OF STUDENTS IS BEING
CONNED OUT OF A REAL EDUCATION
BY UNSCRUPULOUS AND GREEDY
TEACHERS UNIONS HELL-BENT ON
USING THE PANDEMIC TO THEIR
ADVANTAGE.
AS A RESULT, SCHOOLS ALL OVER
OUR COUNTRY ARE STILL SHUT DOWN
AND KIDS HAVE BEEN FORCED INTO
ONLINE LEARNING AND THE COST HAS
BEEN STAGGERING.
FOR INSTANCE, IN LOS ANGELES,
SCHOOLS AND SAW A SHARP DROP IN
KINDERGARTEN ENROLLMENT, ABOUT
6,000 STUDENTS.
IN ST. PAUL, MINNESOTA, 40% OF
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS HAVE
FAILING GRADES, 40%.
EVEN HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF KIDS
IN HOUSTON, TEXAS, ARE FAILING
AT LEAST TWO CLASSES.
IN OUR NATION’S CAPITAL, THERE’S
BEEN A 14 PERCENTAGE POINT DROP
AMONG BLACK STUDENTS IN
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
SECOND GRADE WHO MET LITERACY
STANDARDS, AND JUST 20 MILES
AWAY IN FAIRFAX COUNTY,
VIRGINIA, A NEW SURVEY OF
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE IN SCHOOLS
FOUND THAT F LETTER GRADES ARE
UP -- ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
83% THIS YEAR.
FOR FAIRFAX MIDDLE SCHOOLERS,
Fs ARE UP 300%.
>> YOUR CHILDREN’S EDUCATION,
YOUR JOBS AND INCOMES, YOUR
OTHER RESPONSIBILITIES HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUS.
WE ALSO COULD NOT BE PROUDER OF
HOW OUR STUDENTS AND STAFF HAVE
STEPPED UP TO LEARN AND TO TEACH
IN NEW WAYS AND HOW EVERYONE HAS
ADAPTED TO THESE CHALLENGES.
>> Tammy: WOW, HOW EVERYONE
HAS ADAPTED -- THIS ISN’T LIKE
GOING FROM A B STUDENT TO A C
STUDENT, THIS SYSTEM IS FAILING
THESE STUDENTS.
IT ARE BEING LEFT BEHIND,
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS AREN’T
GETTING THE HELP THEY NEED, GET
THE TEACHERS UNIONS WANT THE
SCHOOLS TO SAY CLOSED.
EVEN MORE POWER UNDER THE BITE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE WIN THIS ELECTION, YOU’RE
GOING TO GET THE SUPPORT YOU
NEED AND SUPPORT YOU DESERVE,
YOU WON’T JUST HAVE A PARTNER IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Tammy: THAT SHOULD BE
CONCERNING TO SOME PEOPLE AND
JOINING ME NOW IS OFFER MY -- CY
GARRETT, EDUCATION ACTIVIST AND
FOUNDER OF CYNTHIA GARRETT
MINISTRIES AND AUTHOR OF I
CHOOSE VICTORY, THAT IS A GREAT
TITLE, THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME,
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tammy: I WAS JUST IN
RELATING THAT TO OUR AUDIENCE,
THE NUMBERS ARE SHOCKING.
WE’VE HAD SHOCKING NEWS THIS
YEAR ESPECIALLY OUT OF FAIRFAX,
HOW ARE PARENTS DOING AND ISN’T
THERE -- I THINK THERE MIGHT BE
AN UPRISING OR THERE SHOULD BE
TO DEAL WITH THE ENTIRE SCHOOL
BOARD, WHAT’S GOING ON OUT THERE
THERE?
>> PARENTS ARE SO ANGRY, THE MAN
YOU JUST HEARD IS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF
FAIRFAX COUNTY, PARENTS NOW HAVE
THIS BUMPER STICKER ON THEIR
CARS.
THEY HAVE FIRE, AUDIT -- I WAS
SO ANGRY LISTENING TO YOUR
SEGMENT JUST NOW, THE DATA ON
POOR KIDS WHO ARE FAILING NOW
BECAUSE WE HAVE A SUPERINTENDENT
WHO IS FAILING OUR CHILDREN.
SCOTT BRABRAND HAS FAMOUSLY SAID
EQUITY IS AT THE HEART OF HIS
INITIATIVE AND WHAT HE HAS DONE
IS HE HAS BECOME AN ACTIVIST
INSTEAD OF AN EDUCATOR AND WHAT
HE’S DOING IS FAILING THE KIDS
THAT HE SUPPOSEDLY TRYING TO
REACH.
USUALLY THE DATA IS PLUS 34% BUT
RIGHT NOW THE NUMBER OF KIDS WHO
ARE ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
AND FAILING ARE 1 OUT OF 5, OR 1
LEARNERS, 1 OUT OF 3, AND OUR
BOYS, 1 OUT OF 10.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
WHAT WE HAVE IS A LOST YEAR,
JUST LIKE YOU SAID.
IT’S A POLITICAL SCANDAL, IT’S A
TRAVESTY, AND OUR SUPERINTENDENT
IS MAKING MORE THAN $300,000 A
YEAR.
IT’S HORRIBLE, IT’S SO
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Tammy: THERE ARE SO MANY
DIFFERENT FRONTS TO THIS, YOU’VE
GOT TEACHERS UNIONS AND
POLITICAL INTEREST THERE, YOU’VE
GOT THE IMPACT PSYCHOLOGICALLY
ON CHILDREN, IF YOU GET A F, YOU
FAIL AT A YOUNG AGE, IT SETS
INTO MOTION ATTITUDES AND
FRAMEWORK IN ADDITION OF COURSE
TO THE PEOPLE GETTING RICH IN
THIS FRAMEWORK AS THOUGH THEY
ARE USELESS OR THROWAWAYS, WHAT
IS YOUR TAKE ON WHAT PARENTS CAN
DO CONSIDERING THE LONG-TERM
IMPACT.
THIS ISN’T JUST ONE YEAR THAT IS
LOST BUT THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
IMPACT ON CHILDREN OVERALL.
>> YOU’RE RIGHT, THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT IS
INCREDIBLE BECAUSE YOU AND I
BOTH KNOW THAT WHEN YOU GET A F,
YOU GET A FAILING GRADE, THE
WORD FAIL IS SORT OF ON YOUR
FOREHEAD.
STUDENTS TEND TO WITHDRAW, THEY
BECOME MORE AND MORE RESISTANT
TO LEARNING, SO THE INEQUITY GAP
HAS JUST GOTTEN WIDER AND WIDER.
KIDS WHO ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING -- NOW THEY ARE WAY
BEHIND.
I THINK SO MUCH OF WHAT PARENTS
CAN DO HAS GOT TO DO WITH
SHOWING UP, YOU’VE GOT TO START
TO SHOW UP IN A CLASSROOM, AT
THE BOARD MEETINGS, WE’VE GOT TO
SHOW UP AND WE HAVE TO SPEAK UP
AND WE HAVE TO GET ANGRY AND WE
HAVE TO START DEMANDING CHANGE.
>> Tammy: I WOULD LIKE BOTH OF
YOU TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT JOE BIDEN HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THE REOPENING OF SCHOOLS, LISTEN
TO THIS.
>> WHAT WILL YOU DO TO GET KIDS
BACK IN SCHOOL, HOW MUCH WILL
YOU BE WORKING THE PHONES AND
WORKING WITH GOVERNORS AND
MAYORS?
>> IT TAKES A LOT OF MONEY TO
GET THEM BACK, THE ESTIMATES ARE
152 MECCA $250 BILLION A YEAR TO
SEE IF WE SCHOOLS.
>> Tammy: DOES THAT SAY IT
ALL -- SUDDENLY IT IS ABOUT
MONEY, BUT SAVING MONEY COME A
BUNCH OF THINGS THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH WORRYING
ABOUT THE KIDS AND AMERICA IN
GENERAL IS AGREEING THAT THERE
IS NO REASON TO NOT HAVE THESE
SCHOOLS OPEN, ISN’T THAT KIND OF
A CONFESSION ABOUT WHAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT?
>> WHAT IS LOST IN THIS IS OUR
CHILDREN, THAT IS WHAT IS THE
TRAGEDY.
RIGHT HERE IS THE BOOK THAT OUR
SUPERINTENDENT PAID $20,000 TO
HAVE THIS AUTHORS SPEAK FOR ONE
HOUR, ONE HOUR.
JUST IMAGINE THAT HE IS JUST
PUTTING IN SAFETY MECHANISMS
RIGHT NOW FOR OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS
AND YET FAILING OUR KIDS.
THERE’S A YOUNG MAN WATCHING YOU
TONIGHT, HIS NAME IS TEDDY, HE
WOKE UP AT 5:45:00 A.M. THE SIGN
UP FOR THE LAST SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING BECAUSE HE WANTED TO BEG
THE SUPERINTENDENT TO OPEN UP
SCHOOLS, HE WAS SO EXCITED, HE
WAS GOING TO GO BACK A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO AND ON THE EVE OF HIS
RETURN, CANCELED.
IF SCHOOL WAS CANCELED, THEY ARE
JUST PLAYING AROUND WITH KIDS’
LIVES.
AND MEANWHILE, THEY ARE GOING
AFTER THIS SOCIAL JUSTICE
ACTIVISM.
MY SON GOES TO HIGH SCHOOL,
SCOTT BRABRAND, THE
SUPERINTENDENT HAS BEEN AT WAR
WITH THIS HIGH SCHOOL’S PARENTS
AND STUDENTS TO CHANGE
ADMISSIONS TO "INCLUDE EQUITY."
, MEANWHILE, HE HAS SUCH
INJUSTICE IN THE WAY HE’S
ACTUALLY EDUCATING OUR KIDS.
THEY GET A F GRADE AND OUR
KIDS --
>> Tammy: WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT IS THE BIGGEST FACTOR
IN SCHOOL SHUTDOWNS?
WE’VE GOT A NEW STUDY FOR THE
WISCONSIN INSTITUTE OF LAW AND
LIBERTY, THEY FOUND THE PRESENCE
OF A TEACHERS UNION WAS MORE OF
A DECIDING FACTOR FOR A
WISCONSIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHOOSING TO DIRECT THEIR CLASSES
VIRTUALLY, NOT THE EXTENT OF THE
PANDEMIC ITSELF IN THE COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY.
THAT’S APPARENTLY CONSISTENT
WITH NATIONAL RESEARCH -- WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING IS IT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH SCIENCE OR
WHAT’S BEST FOR YOUR KIDS,
WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON THAT?
>> WE KNOW IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH SCIENCE, THE SCIENCES
ALWAYS ALWAYS SAID THAT CHILDREN
ARE NOT REALLY THE ONES AT RISK.
I THINK THAT A LOT OF THIS IN MY
ESTIMATION -- I LOOK AT IT
HONESTLY, I JUST GO I KNOW WE’VE
BEEN LAZY IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I KNOW THAT THERE’S BEEN A
LOT OF MONEY THROWN AT WHAT’S
CALLED THE PROBLEM, FIXING THE
PROBLEM.
BUT HONESTLY PART OF THE PROBLEM
I THINK IS THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO REALLY AND TRULY LIKE
IN SOME SENSE WHAT’S GOING ON.
THAT MAY SOUND HARSH BUT THAT’S
HOW I FEEL.
>> Tammy: I THINK YOU’RE
RIGHT, THAT’S WHAT A LOT OF US
HAVE SEEN.
IT’S A BIG QUESTION, IT’S BEEN
EIGHT MONTHS.
THIS IS NOW VERY SERIOUS, A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE STILL BEING MOVED
THROUGH FEAR.
I WANT TO THANK YOU BECAUSE NOW